heureusement pour toujours n'existe que dans les
contes de fées
mais un ours en peluche qui parle est sur le point d'
épouser sa petite amie je vous
déclare maintenant ours en peluche et femme laissez-moi embrasser l'ours
prouvant que les américains ne se soucient
de rien
alors j'ai de grandes nouvelles tammy  lynn et moi
allons avoir un bébé qui est génial
attends comment vous les gars nous euh nous avons besoin d'un
beignet de sperme
qu'est-ce que tu fais pour te
préparer mec quand est-ce que tu te prépares
qu'est-ce que tu fais dans ta
main je suis  faire ça pour toi alors quand
je rentre je peux juste le casser bien tu
penses que tu es un homard rouge
hey johnny tu l'as fait ici mon pote
attrape ce qui se passe mec c'est le
combat d'enfant de quelqu'un c'est un
mec de merde c'est dans mes yeux je suis  le faire clignoter
oh attends attends je vais prendre une
photo et la poster sur facebook quel
hashtag gir lundi
oh mon dieu nounours regarde ça ça dit si
on veut avoir un bébé tu vas
devoir prouver que tu es une personne  dans un
tribunal c'est un cauchemar nous devons le
combattre nous aurons une loi  toi et nous poursuivrons le
gouvernement pour tes droits civiques
je suis samantha jackson qui doit être ted euh
ouais samantha jackson quel est ton deuxième
prénom leslie oh mon dieu tu es sam l
jackson c'est super pour moi tout comme sam
l jackson
qui est  que tu as déjà vu un film
c'est le gars noir
ils t'ont refusé les mêmes droits que
tout le monde juste parce que tu es
différent peux tu me rendre ma vie
ted crois tu que tu as une âme
que pensais tu que je ferais
en ce moment,
vous voulez être humain aux yeux de la
loi, l'important dans le fait d'être
humain est de contribuer à la
société
où diable est mon café, vous ne construisez pas de
fusées.
biscuit croustillant
dans le cul de ce mec, faites-le, je
vais le faire
oh mon dieu qui a fait ça oh monsieur, je
m'excuse pour mon enfant de cinq ans, bad
butch, vous êtes assis là et battez vos pépites de poisson, d'
accord, je vais demander  vous si vous testez des
questions maintenant vous êtes
prêt  vous vous considérez comme une
objection humaine soutenue non le témoin
ne peut pas être annulé par
une
mallette de spéculation coupable pour dieu dans ma chambre arrêtez le
castor sur l'arrestation du témoin nous pourrions
totalement être des avocats